[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce journal
du jeudi 21 novembre sur tv 78 voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
la venue ce matin du premier ministre
edouard philippe à guyancourt accompagné
de la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud
il s'est rendu au campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité un
déplacement pour lancer la nouvelle
application mon compte formation plus de
700 entreprises présentes au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
quatrième sky business days se dérouler
aujourd'hui une convention d'affaires
pour faciliter les rencontres entre
grands comptes tpe pme et start-up du
territoire et c'était hier les 30 ans de
la convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant adoptée le 20 novembre 1989
à l'onu à cette occasion la ville de
montigny le bretonneux organisait ce
mercredi une grande journée d'animations
et puis le bilan dans cette émission de
scola la deuxième boutique éphémère de
l'espace saint quentin et qui baissent
le rideau demain un métier sur 2
évoluera profondément d'ici dix ans avec
l'application mon compte formation il
est possible désormais de trouver une
formation plus simplement cette
nouveauté a été lancée ce matin au
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité à guyancourt par le
premier ministre et la ministre du
travail sur place manon varaldo muriel
pénicaud ministre du travail et edouard
philippe premier ministre ont lancé
l'application mon compte formation au
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité à guyancourt
cette application permet de s'inscrire
directement en formation sans passer par
un intermédiaire l'objectif faire
décoller la formation professionnelle en
france
il ya simplement une personne sur trois
qui vont en formation chaque année il ya
beaucoup plus d'aspiration évolué et
puis ya beaucoup
plus souci d'évolution des métiers on
sait qu'on avait en france un accès à la
formation professionnelle qui était très
en deçà des besoins très en dessous de
ce qu'on pouvait faire
et probablement parce qu'il y avait des
gens qui ne connaissaient pas leurs
droits
mon compte formation permet de connaître
ses droits à des formations puis de
trouver de réserver et de payer la
formation de son choix
ça peut en voir changer de métier sur
l'entreprise pour un demandeur d'emploi
s'est trouvé un emploi
il n'avait qu'une qualification on a
trois fois plus de chances de trouver un
emploi
l'application est ouverte à tous les
salariés et demandeurs d'emploi patrick
pereira salarié d'une entreprise de
déménagement souhaitent se former au
parmi pour chariots élévateurs
il s'inscrit en direct avec son numéro
de sécurité sociale son email et en
créant un mot de passe tu fais partie et
c'est parti bon nombre d'inscriptions il
à l'organisme de formation à 48 heures
pour répondre
le compte est crédité de 500 euros par
an 800 pour les salariés non qualifiés
les formations diplômantes ou
certifiantes tourne autour des 1400
euros
il n'est pas très courant qu'on dise à
25 millions de français c'est beaucoup
quand même 25 millions de français vous
avez un droit et vous ne l'exercé pas
aujourd'hui mais grâce à ça vous allez
pouvoir l'exercer
plus de 100000 formations sont proposées
actuellement sur mon compte formation un
mot de politique locale avec les
élections municipales qui se tiennent
les 15 et 22 mars prochains
la confirmation a été donnée hier le
maire sortant divers gauche de trappes
guy malandain reçoit le soutien du parti
présidentiel de la république en marche
l'élu est en lice pour un quatrième
mandat il a annoncé sa candidature il ya
de cela un an
face à lui sont confirmés pour le moment
son adjoint ali rabais pour la liste
pour que tu rappes respirer le
conseiller municipal d'opposition
othman nas coûts associés à mustapha
larbaoui la quatrième édition du à sky
business day s'est tenue aujourd'hui au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à suivre un
reportage sur l'événement dans un
instant en parallèle le service mobilité
de l'agglomération présentait ses offres
diversifiées les différents projets
d'innovation en matière de transport
marche augmenté services de trottinettes
électriques applications présentant les
mobilités possible jusqu'aux projets les
plus conséquents comme supra sky
l'agglomération souhaite
conforter son image d'innovation et se
montrer ambitieux sur le secteur le
directeur des mobilités de saint quentin
en yvelines au micro de marylène yapi
chinois notre positionnement
géographique et en grande couronne
et donc on a des spécificités par
rapport à la zone dense puisque dit bibi
est typiquement on a pas de métro on n'a
pas de tramway donc on a un très bon
réseau de bus mais on voit bien que pour
se déplacer mieux à saint quentin il ya
besoin de compléter sa et de l'amplifier
donc l'enjeu pour l'agglomération c'est
une stratégie qui a été voté par les
élus en 2014 dans le plan local de
déplacement
c'est d'amplifier le bouquet de services
de mobilité sur saint-quentin
présentation durant je vous le disais le
sky business day au vélodrome nationale
mille personnes ont assisté à cette
convention d'affaires qui vise à faire
se rencontrer les entreprises du
territoire saint quentinois le deuxième
pôle économique et de l'ouest parisien
est nicolas d'andry et patrick jacques
de dixmude ont passé la matinée sur
l'événement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la tradition maintenant depuis quatre
ans le sky business day est lancée avec
ce gong
un événement qui rassemble 700
entreprises 4000 rendez vous entre les
acteurs économiques
alors comment on fait du business à
saint quentin en yvelines nous sommes
allés leur poser la question je trouve
que c'est très dynamique mais secteur
sont variés et en termes d'innovation
technologique et à haut potentiel il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises innovantes sur le
territoire de saint quentin qui sont
représentés ici et j'essaie d'entrer en
contact avec elle pour leur apporter une
expertise en matière de protection de
l'innovation il ya un fort potentiel de
collaborative puisque c'est un foyer
entreprises déjà c'est la quatrième
édition pour nous au sky business day et
ses traits générateurs de business et de
contacts intéressants également en
termes de partenariats et pas seulement
en terme de futurs clients
[Musique]
avec jean michel fourgous président de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour
bonjour alors c'est la quatrième édition
c'est un événement qui s'inscrit
vraiment dans le calendrier de
l'agglomération dans l'accompagnement
des petites entreprises
faire plus réussir leur simplifier la
vie notamment dans cette partie d'aller
conquérir des clients puisque c'est
comme ça quand sur une boîte quand elle
va chercher des clients et donc c'est
déterminant et là on est sur cette étape
là ce moment de l'entreprise on et
landreau besson beaucoup de sujets mais
là aujourd'hui c'est ce sujet la
rencontre et plus de clients soit
beaucoup plus structurée qui est bien le
temps de bien préparer leur argumentaire
qui échangent avec l'échangé aussi une
suite derrière
donc ça maximalise jeu qu'on appelle les
rendez-vous prospects en quoi c'est
important en tant que communauté
d'agglomération de mettre en relation
les entreprises de son territoire
d'abord c'est l'argent de 55 ans j'ai
réussi 1
si une règle de territoires bien sûr et
on est le 2ème pib par habitant après
paris vous le savez donc on est là pour
pour conserver aussi pour pourquoi les
entreprises de saint quentin elles sont
dix sept mille je crois eh bien elle
travaille encore plus ensemble et que
surtout les les petits puissent plus
facilement avoir accès aux gros parce
que c'est quand même deux mondes
différents pour avoir accès à une boîte
du cac 40 quand vous êtes une petite
boîte de moins de 10 personnes c'est
quasiment impossible donc on est là pour
résoudre ce problème
rapprocher les petits et gros que les
gros et plus les petits parce que bien
sûr
et c'est le cas c'est une réussite savez
la quatrième fois les entreprises les
petits autour d'une remontée et les gros
ceci d'accord ils sont conscients aussi
que d'aider les petits jeux peillac
simplement solidarité mais presque une
entreprise sans appel c'est le social
c'est pas moi mr au prix dans l'agglo
qui fait le ciel c'est les entreprises
donc je suis chaud on est chargé ici de
développer et de préparer les relais et
donc ici c'est pousser à accélérer
accompagne à aller plus vite encore à
monter plus vite pour nos petites
entreprises et c'est le but bien sûr de
cet événement merci jean michel fourgous
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le skull &
business day c'est aussi l'occasion de
présenter les innovations créé et
développé à saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça
se passe ici sur le village des
innovations
[Musique]
ans
l une des innovations présentées ici sur
le sky business day dans le village
innovation elle est présentée par la
start-up refus olmi gouel garantie au
bonjour bonjour vous êtes co fondateur
de cette start up
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter déjà l'idée comment elle a
germé dans votre esprit alors oui
cofondateur avec mon frère comment elle
a germé c'est simple des stations
service sont en disparition de plus en
plus donc on s'est décidé à amener le
carburant et apporter ce service qui
dans les grandes métropoles est vraiment
compliqué aller à la station vous êtes
apporté à trappes c'est une idée que
vous avez développé depuis combien de
temps alors quatre années de recherche
et développement dont beaucoup de soude
investi on a travaillé avec le
législateur et avec tout les tous les
organismes qui gèrent un petit peu la
matière dangereuse et nous sommes
installés à exactement comment ça
fonctionne concrètement alors comment ça
fonctionne c'est très simple on a des
méthodes dématérialiser la commande vous
avez une application avec votre
smartphone vous est géolocalisé vous
commandez en temps direct il ya un temps
qui s'affiche
minute par exemple donc notre camion
reçoit l'information
il vient votre voiture là vous recevez
un autre message en disant notre
véhicule est en approche de lui ouvrir
la trappe à essence
hélas ce moment là l'autre chauffeur
s'installe à côté de votre véhicule créé
une mini zone atex
voilà une mini zone atex faut savoir que
chauffeur sont formés parce que je suis
un centre de formation
il sert le
véhicule ensuite il vous fait les pneus
lisses et en véhicules en essence il
fait les pneus et repart et se débite et
via l'application
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
[Musique]
un autre événement dédié aux sociétés
les rencontres de la création
d'entreprise
elle se tenait en début de semaine à
versailles c'était la deuxième édition à
l'hôtel de ville organisée par
l'association suzanne michaud plus de
200 participants étaient réunis
créateurs d'entreprises associations et
porteurs de projets le but faire se
rencontrer ces acteurs autour d'un
événement convivial les propos
recueillis par michael et le mindoro de
pouvoir échanger de pouvoir sortir d'un
cadre ou bien souvent en tant
qu'entrepreneur individuel et non pelées
travaille seul et en ont besoin de
rencontrer de partager des idées de
constituer un réseau et c'est aussi
l'occasion pour eux de rencontrer des
partenaires
tout ça très dynamique en plus il ya de
nombreux comment dire de nombreuses
associations qui sont là pour nous aider
c'est très riche
moi ça me convient parfaitement ça
répond à mes besoins plus de 150 postes
à pourvoir sur place le forum de
l'emploi de coignières se dérouler ce
jeudi c'était dans les salons antoine de
saint-exupéry plus de 60 entreprises
étaient représentées l'occasion
d'échanger et de déposer un cv le rendez
vous se focaliser sur les secteurs dits
en tension c'est à dire qu'ils recrutent
restauration en bâtiments publics
transports services à la personne
informatique ou encore environnement une
nouveauté cette année pour proposer des
offres concrètes de travail les
explications au micro de mathilde et
demi il ya effectivement sur le bassin
de saint quentin
il ya des entreprises qui sont en
recherche de salariés et nous on a
probablement des salariés à proposer
donc qu'il fallait faire la jonction
entre l'entreprise et les salariés les
salariés qui recherche et l'entreprise
qui recherchent aussi et donc on a pensé
que c'était effectivement la bonne
formule pour
pour faciliter les choses eux aussi sont
dans une démarche de recherche d'emploi
20 stagiaires ont travaillé pendant deux
mois au sein de scola cette deuxième
boutique éphémère ferme ses portes
demain au centre commercial espace saint
quentin à montigny le bretonneux l'heure
de dresser le bilan avec mes invités
l'audi no et bonsoir chef de projet et
formatrice à ce qu'aulas et il ya
également nominé xavier bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir vous avez été tous les deux
donc stagiaire au sein de cette boutique
éphémère et l'audi no go on rappelle le
principe de scola c'est une véritable
boutique école pour apprendre le métier
de vendeur c'est ça c'est une boutique
créée pour vingt stagiaires alors recrue
est recruté en partenariat avec pôle
emploi
le dispositif scola c'est un dispositif
innovant formation créée par la
fondation des apprentis d'auteuil en
finance est financé grâce au plan
d'investissement des compétences de
l'état et au fonds social européen et on
accompagne 20 jeunes donc informations
sur le savoir-être professionnels sur
les techniques de vente pour obtenir un
diplôme qui s'appelle le diplôme de
vendeurs conseillers magasin d'accord
escola qui n'est pas présent qu'à saint
quentin en yvelines là il y avait une
boutique éphémère à saint quentin en
yvelines mais il y en a d'autres aussi
par exemple à vélizy il y en a eu en
d'autres lieux à vélizy en a une
quinzaine en tout en france et
actuellement il y en avait une à saint
quentin en yvelines et une aéro vide
pourquoi apprendre justement les
techniques de vente sous cette forme
pourquoi c'est intéressant alors le
constat par en fait des difficultés des
managers dans les métiers de la vente à
recruter la plupart du temps pour des
problèmes de savoir être professionnel
donc cette formation c'est la seule
formation qui ont deux mois permet
d'avoir un diplôme reconnu par l'état
d'être formés en savoir être et d'avoir
une expérience terrain donc le
recrutement
ce sont des jeunes entre 18 et 30 ans
qui veulent aller dans l'insertion
professionnelle dans les métiers de la
vente et qui ont maximum un niveau bac
vous parlez de la formation c'est une
formation qui mêle à la fois de la
pratique on est directement dans cette
boutique scola à l'espace saint quentin
il y aussi un volet théorique c'est ça
pendant ces deux mois
oui l'organisme de formation sème donc
ali
une partie en boutique et une partie en
formation alors je me tourne vers
justement ces jeunes qui ont participé à
cette boutique éphémère juste de savoir
quelles étaient vos missions sur place
noémie gravier à l'ennemi quelles
étaient vos missions sur place pendant
deux mois l'information un théorique et
pratique en même temps dans une petite
en fait dans la boutique on apprend
vraiment la technique des ventes on
allait vers les clients d expliquer la
cua set disco l'a ensuite en esprit on
explique la les étapes de la vendre on
applique il est appelé à des lavandes et
la découverte des clients donc il ya pas
mal de choses qui ont été abordés sur
cette formation sur les deux mois sur
les produits vendus au sein de cette
boutique on était sur des produits de
créateurs français des créateurs locaux
voilà c'est ça le créneau c'est de ça
qu'on portait pour lancer notre speech
envers les cantons étaient en face des
clients on expliquer le concept de la
boutique et ensuite le concept des
créateurs qui veulent avoir de la
visibilité que nous puisse se former sur
la vente de leurs produits
quels types de créateurs par exemple
prêt-à-porter faye est bon on avait
principalement du prêt-à-porter féminin
on avait un petit peu de prêt-à-porter
homme et sinon on avait aussi de la
tisane et quel bilan alors à tour de
rôle vous tiré de cette expérience nous
a dit qu'ils allaient le bilan vous
faites après ces deux mois cette
expérience s'achève demain la boutique
éphémère fermera ses portes demain
quelle est l'expérience que vous tirez
j'ai appris plein de choses pendant la
formation de scola j'ai appris à aller
voir les clients maîtriser la table les
étapes de la vente
j'ai appris une pleine formation les et
aussi les formatrices son extraordinaire
il nous a accompagnés jusqu'à la fin de
notre formation
le bilan xavier de l'autre côté bah moi
le bilan il est assez satisfaisant
scellés on était très bien encadrés par
les par les eaux et les personnes qui
est légal et formatrice
nous a appris à nous connaître nous
mêmes on a appris à nous à se faire
confiance à oser justement et en deux
mois je pense qu'on a tous à peu près
réussi à atteindre les objectifs que
vous voulez maintenant le dernier objet
petit c'est le dernier objectif c'est le
diplôme en espérant qu'on connaît tous
il ya moins important et l'audi no et
c'est la confiance il ya un vrai travail
qui a été réalisé sur la confiance on
avait diffusé un reportage sur le début
de l'expérience cola il ya deux mois où
le champion du monde de kick boxing qui
intervenait auprès des jeunes aurélien
duhamel étaient intervenus l'objectif
c'est vraiment alors parfois ils sont
éloignés de l'emploi parfois ils ont eu
un parcours scolaire qui s'arrêtait un
peu tôt et c'est vraiment de qui se
reconnecte a qui sont à leur talent leur
valeur et qui pis surtout se valoriser
alors en entretien et aussi après en
montrant tout leur savoir être
professionnel et vous donc qui est chef
de projet formatrice sur scola sur ce
projet scola
quel est le bilan que vous tirez vous
sur sur ces deux mois alors au bout des
deux mois alors par exemple si je prends
ce qu'on a déjà terminé
il ya à peu près 80 % taux de retour
soit l'emploi soit retour sur sur des
formations diplômantes donc ça c'est
pour les personnes qui ont participé à
la première boutique éphémère l'an passé
de ce fait la première et la deuxième à
vélizy d'accord et ensuite sur l'année
dernière il y en a eu il y en a eu qu'un
des stagiaires cas pas eu son diplôme
sur le groupe
ça veut dire que concrètement quand on
passe via scola on a une grande chance
de rebondir après de rebondir et oui
depuis d'apprendre sur soi et de voir
les choses autrement vous comment vous
envisagez justement la suite maintenant
que vous avez eu cette expérience
voilà comment de quoi sera fait votre
avenir en tout cas ma pour moi j'y vais
suivant la vente
ensuite j'ai l'intention dé suivre
passer des plots mode sur par la suite
aimé de tous les moments je vais passer
un bon moment voilà vous vous êtes
encore sur sur la fin de cette
expérience vous l'imaginez comment vous
la suite bon moi je pensais partir
continuer sur une certification pour
aller au niveau dessus et ensuite
pouvoir partir tranquillement
au canada je crois que les jeunes qui
avaient participé l'année dernière à ce
qu elle avait pu travailler pendant la
période des fêtes à l'espace saint
quentin est ce que ça c'est en
discussion est ce que c'est possible
c'est possible et c'est déjà le cas donc
font tous un stage de quinze jours et
certains à la place du stage ont déjà
trouvé un cdd est ce que l'expérience
sera renouvelée l'année prochaine le
sait pas encore il ya des dispositifs
scola qui sont prévus pour l'instant on
ne sait pas encore exactement où met on
en aura normalement 4 en ile-de-france
bien merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce plateau à ce journal
elodie anneaux et merci également à nos
amis et à xavier qui ont été parmi les
vingt stagiaires de cette deuxième
boutique éphémère scola au sein de
l'espace saint quentin et je rappelle
que cette boutique éphémère fermera ses
portes demain dans le centre commercial
saint quentinois autre centre commercial
celui-ci flambant neuf dans le nord des
yvelines à buchelay situé près du péage
de l'a 13
mon beau buchelay a été inaugurée hier
mercredi un site de 30 mille mètres
carrés co qui comprendra 54 enseigne à
terme le centre espère attirer chaque
année entre 3 et 4 millions de visiteurs
pour accueillir les clients 300 emplois
ont été créés 100 millions d'euros
investis on écoute les différentes
réactions au micro de michael et demi
d'euros ça fait dix ans que les élus ont
pensé à lancer la restructuration
lanières rénovation de la cité la zone
commerciale de buchelay et aujourd'hui
nous ouvrons
ce site il s'appelle mon beau buchelay
avec cette offre qualitative très
importante on va pouvoir aussi
restructurer une zone commerciale qui
avaient énormément d i et qui ne
correspondaient plus aux canons
contemporain du commerce le département
cofinance avec la communauté urbaine à
moitié la réalisation des travaux
d'infrastructures routières
[Musique]
il ya 30 ans l'organisation des nations
unies adoptée ce document à l'unanimité
la convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant
pour son anniversaire le 20 novembre le
service jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux invité les enfants de la
commune a fêté leur droit c'était à
l'hôtel de ville marie lehn iapichino
revient sur l'événement
[Musique]
les petits envahissent l'hôtel de ville
de montigny le bretonneux pour fêter
leurs droits le service jeunesse de la
commune a organisé cette journée
spéciale pour le 30e anniversaire de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
l'objectif de cette journée c'est de
sensibiliser les enfants déjà sur leurs
droits
on est quand même sur une tranche d'âge
6 12 ans je pense qu'ils ont besoin de
savoir et de connaître leurs droits leur
a rappelé que eux aussi on sait bien
aussi un moment donné de savoir ce qu'on
a de faire un état des lieux petit peu
ben non dans ma ville qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce que qu'est-ce qui est
mis en place de nombreux ateliers
étaient proposés comme ce débat mené par
les membres du conseil municipal des
jeunes les enfants sont amenés à recréer
une assemblée et doivent réfléchir à des
solutions pour kamini un garçon de 10
ans harcelé à l'école ça permet de
savoir comment le conseil municipal fait
pour rechercher des trucs pour s'occuper
de la ville plus loin un autre groupe
réfléchit sur le droit de bien manger en
recréant un des logo de l'unicef en
fruits
vous avez utilisé des fruits pour les
vitamines une pomme un quart de
clémentine des myrtilles de la cranberry
pour un personnage symbole et de leurs
droits
une journée de fête pour tous les
enfants en messages importants et bien
digéré
marylène iapichino qui a profité de son
reportage pour demander aux enfants ils
montrent un quel était leur droit
écoutez on a le droit de se réunir le
droit de jouer j'ai le droit d'aller à
l'école
j'ai le droit d'être logés on a le droit
d'être soigné a le droit de s'amuser
voilà pour ses 30 ans de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
le 3e salon de la rénovation énergétique
est élu au programme dimanche dernier à
chevreuse les particuliers voulant
emmener chez eux des travaux de
rénovation énergétique pouvait
rencontrer les entreprises et artisans
qualifiés du secteur
mathilde et demi de stand en stand
yoann est à la recherche d'un architecte
ou d'un maître d'oeuvre qui pourrait
l'aider à construire sa maison mais sur
des principes qui respecte
l'environnement on soit construit une
maison sur des principes bioclimatiques
voilà donc une maison qui serait
autonome en énergie et qui serait
autonome en eau aussi que de la
récupération d'eau de pluie changer de
mode de vie a un prix même si de plus en
plus de particuliers optent pour la
rénovation énergétique
les travaux sont conséquents et
nécessite une réflexion souvent les
artisans vont conseille de commencer par
les fenêtres ce qui est très coûteux
on a vite un budget autour de vingt
mille euros pour des fenêtres pour une
toiture la difficulté ça va être de
savoir si on peut le faire par
l'intérieur ça fait comme une facture
qui va vite monté autour de 20000 euros
aussi et sur les murs et tour c'est
aussi notre ordre là pendant le salon
l'association alex caille avec la
plateforme repères habitat propose un
accompagnement personnalisé aux
particuliers dans leur démarche de
rénovation
les entreprises partenaires de la
plateforme peuvent alors proposer des
devis aux visiteurs on fournit donc une
liste d'artisans donc ça peut être au
début dans un premier temps bureau
d'études et architectes pour bien
préparer son projet et ensuite tous les
artisans du bâtiment quand les travaux
sont terminés
on peut faire un suivi de consommation
et ils peuvent participer au concours
maisons économes
on organise tous les ans un panel
d'entreprises étaient présents pour
proposer le meilleur devis pour des
visiteurs qui se sentent de plus en plus
concernés par la transition énergétique
informations football avant de se
quitter versa est fixé sur son sort
enfin pas tout à fait pour le 8e tour de
la coupe de france le tirage au sort a
eu lieu hier l'équipe yvelinoise est
assuré de jouer à l'extérieur mais ne
connaît pas encore son adversaire ce
sera soit montlouis soi qui est
originaire du centre val de loire où les
normands de virois les deux clubs tous
deux pensionnaires de nationale 3 comme
versailles doivent s'affronter ce
week-end pour le 7e tour de la
compétition le 8e tour de la coupe de
france est lui programmé les 7 et 8
décembre voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi dans un
instant ne manquez pas le 7-8 loisirs
mélanie poquet a sélectionné pour vous
plusieurs idées de sorties à faire ce
week-end sur le territoire quant à moi
je vous retrouve dès lundi pour une
nouvelle édition d'information locale en
direct belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]